ein mord an einer jungen frau
erschüttert ingolstadt ein brutaler mord
der nach einem ehrenmord aussaat der
nimmt jetzt eine unfassbare wendung aber
nochmal zurück die eltern verzweifelt
auf der suche nach ihrer vermissten
tochter fahrt von münchen nach
ingolstadt und machen den grausamen fund
ein lebloser körper auf der rückbank
eines mercedes wird gefunden das opfer
eine junge frau tot
ein brutales verbrechen begangen an
einer jungen deutschen mit irakischen
wurzeln die eltern verzweifelt ihre
tochter wurde ermordet das dachte man
bis jetzt bild chefreporter frank
schneider bei uns jetzt im studio fragen
dieser fall scheint eine unfassbare er
fast schon eher so reale wendung zu
nehmen was genau ist passiert ja es ist
wirklich eine spektakuläre wende die
polizei hat eben mit unseren kollegen in
münchen gesprochen und da haben wir
erfahren dass die tote in dem auto gar
nicht die 23 jährige ist von der wir
ausgegangen sind die ihre eigenen eltern
ja auch betrauert haben sie selber haben
sie ja gefunden und haben sie als ihre
tochter wiedererkannt sondern es handelt
sich wohl um eine doppelgängerin dieser
jungen frau und als täterin konnte jetzt
genau die frau und frage von der mann
dachte sie sei tot nämlich die tochter
dieser eltern und sie soll diese
doppelgängerin zusammen mit einem freund
geliebten das weiß man noch nicht so
genau der aus dem kosovo stammt getötet
haben zur motivlage weist die polizei
momentan noch nichts
wie geht die polizei jetzt damit um dass
dieser fall so eine spektakuläre wende
genommen hat also wie ist man überhaupt
auf diese spur gekommen die polizei sagt
wir haben sehr schnell zweifel daran
gehabt dass es sich wirklich um diese
frau handelt die die eltern aber selber
ja eigentlich wiedererkannt haben da sie
aber mit zig messerstichen getötet wurde
kann man schwer sagen wie entstellt sie
möglicherweise auch war das deshalb
vielleicht eine identifizierung nicht so
einfach war es ist so dass die polizei
wenn eltern ihre eigenes kind
identifizieren in der regel auch gar
keine dna probe entnehmen das heißt wenn
sie wirklich als ziel hat ihren eigenen
tod ihren eigenen mord vorzutäuschen
hätte das gelingen können wenn die
eltern sie identifiziert hätten dann
hätte die polizei keine dna probe
gemacht und dann wäre eine andere person
als sie beerdigt worden
sie hätte möglicherweise woanders mit
diesem kosovarischen man das muss man
jetzt abwarten was die polizei dann noch
zu ermittelt ein neues leben anfangen
können und ihre eltern gedacht sie ist
tot wie geht's jetzt weiter wir gehen
vor allem auch die eltern damit um die
eltern sind erst gerade ganz frisch
informiert wenn die werden natürlich
erstmal froh sein dass ihre tochter
nicht tot ist dann muss ich das erst mal
vorstellen die tochter ist nicht tot
aber jetzt ist sie möglicherweise eine
mörderin das ist so absurd so einen fall
habe ich auch noch nie erlebt muss ich
wirklich sagen das ist wirklich völlig
völlig komisch der ehemann dieser jungen
frau die jetzt als täterin in betracht
kommt der soll sich vor zwei wochen aus
der wohnung geworfen haben ob das auch
schon damit zusammenhängt dass sie
diesen anderen geliebten hat das müssen
wir abwarten und die polizei muss
natürlich jetzt ganz klar aufklären was
ist das motiv weil davon hängt auch ab
ist es ein totschlag oder es ist eben
ein mord frank schneider 29 jahre machst
du diesen job schon und es gibt dennoch
fälle die auch tun noch nicht erlebt
hast absolut vielen dank
[Musik]